the workmen have been told to move
heaven and earth because the mortuaries
are full and the funeral parlors are
overrun the virus has taken hold in the
city of Port Elizabeth and there are
hundreds of bodies to bury like mother
of four Joyce Moni who died in an
overcrowded hospital no one sang or
prayed instead her loved ones looked on
from a distance too fearful to approach
the grave people are so afraid of this
virus and one would say people are
discriminating their own when you'll not
pay the last respect
you throw a piece of soil to say a
goodbye to the person with this pandemic
nothing of the sort happens it's very
sad some thought South Africa had
avoided the worst but the pandemic has
taken root and the country's poorly
managed Health System has begun to
buckle
at Motherwell Hospital residents started
queuing at 2:00 a.m. for kovat tests or
medication and many residents were
clearly desperate are you worried about
kovat very much but I can't can help it
well people they are fasting they are
close to each other I'm very worried
this is terrible sick people are getting
sicker some are dying on the LAX you
know it's hurting it's hurting really
just wonder what our people doing about
this the authorities had months to plan
but the pandemic seems to have taken
them by surprise when protective suits
ran out at one Hospital nurses were
given raincoats instead and there are
some who have had to make their own
every health worker we spoke to talked
of a terrible shortage of staff this
nurse did not want to be identified how
many are missing you can say plus minus
30 messes but last week went from
casualty tested positive and to tested
positive in ICU
it keeps rising and rising and rising he
works at a designated co vyd treatment
facility called livingston hospital and
it appears to be falling apart medical
waste spills out of storerooms and
filthy beds clutter the corridors and
the washing machines are broken so they
can't clean the sheets these pictures
were sent to us by staff members tell me
about the cleanliness oh I wish you
could just go there and see it it's 30
day today today the medical waste you
find it on the floor and there are piles
of linen with feces and flies there are
other things to worry about at
Livingston Hospital like the lack of
beds in intensive care
dedicated doctors are forced to select a
small number for treatment it's
heartbreaking in the sense that you you
end up yourself and your team having to
say no to somebody's mother somebody's
grandmother somebody's father somebody's
uncle do you have a rough idea of how
many referrals get rejected we will
accept roundabouts maybe some 25% of the
Pharos yeah so maybe there's I mean
other 75% is unfortunately not going to
your country I mean we're not going to
get a bid the provincial government has
been given a super-sized field hospital
and opposition parliamentarian Jane
Cowley took us to see it this one-time
car factory boasts 1,400 hospital beds
the German government paying for the
refit but there are only a handful of
patients inside the government doesn't
have the people to run this facility and
they've only just started to recruit
them so I asked how long it was going to
take place within the next week to ten
days
no not realistically hopefully but not
realistically yeah the premiere of this
province admits the health system is
overwhelmed and he's called on military
personnel to assist but the people of
the region are scared and there is
little confidence in those who have been
appointed to protect them John sparks
Sky News Port Elizabeth